just before we get started with the
video today do you want to mention a
brand new channel that I'm hosting
called mega-projects because I didn't
have enough channels mega-projects is a
channel all about mankind's greatest
achievements where I take a deep look at
incredible buildings project structures
and more whether it's the world's most
impressive skyscrapers the International
Space Station or Chernobyl sarcophagus
we cover it all new videos come out a
couple of times a week on mega projects
so if you think it could be for you
please do head over and subscribe it's
linked to below and let's get into it
many of us have grown up with his
stories in some cases some of us even
grew up because of his stories we all
know about his characters the enigmatic
chocolate magnates the six-year-old girl
genius and the Fox and the tortoise but
how much do you know about his
adventures as a fighter pilot his
espionage activities and his
contributions to medicine well join me
today for the inspiring tragic and
controversial story of Roald Dahl Roald
Dahl was born in land F whales on so
Dover 13th 1916 - Norwegian parents
harold and sophie magdalene Hasselbeck
harold and his brother Oscar had left a
small town in Norway in their youth
seeking fortune and adventure Harold had
ended up in Wales establishing a
successful ship broking firm there he
married a French girl marie with whom he
had two children a girl and a boy sadly
Marie died while giving birth to the
latter to recover from this tragedy in
the summer of 1911 Harald traveled back
to Norway where during a trip on a
steamer he met Sophie Magdalene Harold
proposed within a week and the two were
married shortly thereafter the couple
returned to Wales and the family
immediately started to expand their
eldest daughter a street was born in
1912 followed by another girl Alf filled
then rolled and then finally else
Kristen as will learn today the life of
Roald Dahl was time and time again
darkens by tragedies which struck at his
closest relatives the first one happened
in February of nineteen twenty when
Astra died of appendicitis at just seven
years old
the
barely had time to recover when in March
it was patriarch Harold who succumbed to
a pneumonia at the time so if he was
pregnant with the youngest of the doll
girls Astor Sophie sold the dolls large
farmhouse and moved the whole family
including her stepchildren from Harold's
first marriage to a smaller home rolls
words often look up to his mother is an
example of con determination in
difficult times in September of 1923
aged seven Roald was enrolled at land F
Cathedral the preparatory school for
boys characterized by stir discipline
and traditional values in his
autobiographical work boy Roald focuses
on one episode his early school years
the Great Mouse plot of September 1925
rolled in his friends sits an insatiable
sweet tooth in which frequent the candy
shop owned by mrs. pratchett nasty piece
of work with small malignant pig eyes
constantly mistreated by the candy lady
Roald decided to punish her by placing a
dead mouse inside a jar of gobstoppers
when mrs. pratchet dipped a hand into
the container and found the dead rodents
she fainted in shock the shop owner got
her revenge reporting rolled and his
accomplices to the headmaster Koons of
llandaff Cathedral the boys were caned
mercilessly on the buttocks by Koons as
mrs. Pratchett watched with sadistic
glee doll reported that he was caned so
often that even in his adult life he
could not sit for more than two hours
without feeling discomfort in January of
1930 was boarding a trap turn near Dobby
a traditional English public school here
discipline was harsh and Roald was
frequently punished by teachers
Headmaster's and House prefect the
senior pupils a typical humiliation
ritual involved younger children like
rolls being forced to warm up their
seats of outdoor toilets on winter
mornings before the prefix took over the
throne Roald made the most of his time
sitting on the bowl by reading his
favorite authors Charles Dickens William
Thackeray and ambrose bierce the Repton
experience left roles with a profound
distrust of formal Authority which
became evidence in his works of fiction
one of the few good memories from Repton
was related to a nearby Chocolate
Factory
Cadbury's Cadbury's management had
selected reps and students to test new
candy bar recipes so young darlin
friends regularly received big cardboard
boxes full of the best chocolate the
Britain
to offer this first planted the seed of
an idea that somewhere inside a factory
there could be a man inventing new sweet
recipes to delight the taste buds of
downtrodden children in 1934 rolled
turned 17 and he finally left Repton
ready to start University at either
Oxford or Cambridge as was expected from
most middle class young men in those
days but rolls was clearly not most
middle-class men so instead of
continuing his studies he decided to
look for a job one that would allow him
to travel to faraway places he applied
for an apprenticeship at the Shell
petrol company but his teachers had
warned him applicants from more
prestigious schools like eaten or Harrow
would have an advantage roles brought
something to the table that the other
tough kids simply didn't though his
six-foot-four stature and his fighting
skills
you see Roald Dahl was his school's
heavyweight boxing champion the shell
managers were impressed by this kid he
could clearly handle himself in a sticky
situation far from home and they hired
him on the spot
two years later shell sent rolls to DA
s-salam the capital of the East African
British colony of modern-day Tanzania he
loved this work spending as little time
as possible in an office while roaming
the villages and landscapes of the
country this was the type of adventure
that he was craving yet an even bigger
one was just around the corner on
September the 3rd 1939 mr. Chamberlain
in London declared war on Nazi Germany
Roald was conscripted into the Kings
African Rifles leading a platoon of
Ascari's tasked with rounding up and
interning hundreds of German residents
Dahl soon decided that service on land
was not to his taste it rather serve in
the Royal Air Force in November he drove
to Nairobi Kenya to attend flight school
with 15 other trainees out of those 16
only three survived the war
Roald earned his wings by flying
obsolete de Havilland Tiger Moth biplane
with open cockpits the training was made
complicated by his size as his head
stuck out of the cockpit nonetheless
training continued first in Uganda and
then in Hibernia near Baghdad in May
1940 Roald qualified as a pilot and in
August he was commissioned as a second
left
his first post was Elia Egypt where he
was assigned to the near 80 squadron
flying another biplane a Gloster
gladiator on September the 19th 1940
second left-handed Dahl was tasked with
flying his gladiator solo to an airstrip
south of Mercia mattre not far from
Italian forces in Libya with little
instructions no radio and just a map
straps to his knee Dahl managed to reach
the fuuka air base for her refueling
stop from that he set out to Massa Matra
calculating a flight time of 50 minutes
based on further vague instructions
received when he was refueling the mersa
Matruh
was nor it should have been the fifty
minutes were arpund fuel was running
dangerously low dolls only option was to
attempt an emergency landing the
gladiator hit the sand at 75 miles per
hour and Dahl smashed his forehead
against the reflector sites with his
skull and nose fractured his front teeth
knocked out and his eyes temporarily
blind Dahl managed to crawl out of his
Gloucester just in time before the fuel
tank ignited in an explosion the biplane
blew up spraying loose ammunition all
around the desert we can only imagine
that at this point Dahl lit a cigarette
and walked away from the explosion as
slowly as possible and he certainly
didn't look at it more likely he
probably just over to the grounds and
then ran for his life he was later
rescued by a British infantry patrol an
inquiry after the fact revealed that a
commanding officer of phuket provided
the wrong directions for Merce Amara
which was located a further 50 miles to
the south no wonder he had trust issues
with higher authorities Roald had
suffered some pretty serious injuries
requiring a long hospitalization in
Alexandria by 1941 he was discharged and
returned to his squadron by now the
units had ditched the obsolete
gladiators replacing them with more
modern hurricane fighters after a
training period the squadron moved to
Greece
it was April 1941 and Greece was under
the threat of a full-scale axis invasion
his squadron number 80 and squadron
number 33 were placed at a Lucis airbase
under the leadership of a South African
officer named Marmaduke Thomas cynjohn
pattle he was called Pat for short
how was one of the RAF highest-scoring
fighter pilots of world war ii with an
estimated 51 kill
doll described him as possessing the
deeply wrinkled face of a cat who knew
that all of its nine lives had been used
up doll soon realized that the situation
was desperate the Greeks and the Brits
were outnumbered and outgunned by the
Luftwaffe as a fighter pilot dolls main
targets would be the Yunker 88 bombers
heavily armed with front and tail guns
these beasts were as fast as the
Hurricanes despite their size fellow
pilot David Koch brief doll as such the
Greeks are our radar we have a Greek
peasant sitting on top of every mountain
for miles around and when he spots a
bunch of German planes he calls up the
OP through here on the field telephone
that's our radar the day after his
arrival a Toulouse's
April the 15th rolled sauce serious
action chasing six younger eighty-eights
the six bombers were forced to fly
single-file by the mountainous terrain
this made the last plane in the
formation very vulnerable and dull did
not waste the opportunity he fired his
machine guns on the Yonker taking it out
he was relieved to see the German Airmen
parachute to safety
this was Rawls first victory and more
would follow from the 16th to the 19th
each shot down three more yonkers over
the ports of calacas and Piraeus but an
Allied defeat in Greece was not a
situation of if rather than how soon on
April the 20th 1941 allied command
decided to evacuate Greece as the
situation was untenable the RAF had only
12 fighter planes left operational and
they were gathered for a last offensive
action harassing a formation of yonkers
and dawnia bombers heading towards
prayers escorted by at least 200
Luftwaffe fighters the action is
remembered as the Battle of Athens Roald
Dahl's autobiographical work going solo
described the battle as the most
terrifying and exhilarating experience
of his life the formation of hurricanes
was being led by ace of aces Pat pattle
in one hell of a dance around the skies
above the city suddenly the morning
light was dimmed by swarms upon swarms
of incoming German aircraft heavily
outnumbered
Pat's boys did what they could doll shot
at any enemy plane in his sight but he
would never know how many planes he shot
down the enemy was so numerous that he
was too busy avoiding a collision never
mind keeping count of aerial victories
at the end of the battle five hurricanes
had been shot down and three more were
heavily damaged Pat Pat all had in
exhausted his nine lives and was killed
about Athens the battle for Greece was
lost and dull squadron was evacuated and
reconstituted in Haifa Palestine from
there rolled resumed his old sport of
stinging 88's in the tale claiming
another victory on the 15th of June if
you've been keeping accounts this was
Roald Dahl's fifth verified kill as a
fighter pilot making him a certified ace
would he have scored as high as Pat
pattle unfortunately
Dahl had been suffering for a while from
crippling headaches and blackouts almost
certainly a consequence of his accident
in Libya after a blast flight on June
the 23rd he was deemed unfit to fly and
was taken back to England the war was
not over for old though a former RAF
commander met with him in London and
offered him a diplomatic position
Assistant air attache at the British
Embassy in Washington a nice cushy
prestigious job which Dahl hated from
the very start of his mission in April
1942 it became very clear from the start
both to him and his superiors that Dahl
was not suited to diplomacy simply put
he was completely tactless however he
was still in a position to help the
British government in another unique way
serving his country in a more secretive
capacity author Jeanette Conant reports
sow in 1943 Dahl was recruited by
Canadian spy master William Stephenson
into the British security coordination a
spy network whose original mandate had
been to help push the u.s. into the war
even after Pearl Harbor there were still
some influential Americans who remained
Pro isolation resisting the idea of
intervention in the European
Mediterranean war theatres Rao's mission
was important but by no means unpleasant
the aunt who exploiters handsome looks
natural charisma and war hero
reputations who infiltrate wealthy Plex
who may have been conspiring against
Roosevelt or opposing Washington's
commitment to helping London in lay
terms Rawls had to attend dinner parties
balls and dollars and report back any
gossip of interest along the way if he
wooed the affections of a wealthy
socialite even better
among his conquests were the beautiful
congresswoman Clare Boothe Luce as well
as the standard all heiress Millicent
Rogers while spying on the Americans
role took his first steps into the realm
literature his first work was a piece of
cake this was a fictionalized account of
his crash landing in the desert risen at
the insistence of popular author CS
Forester of Captain Honda Fame for us to
thought that his heroic tale may inspire
American readers to support even more
the Allied war effort the short story
was published on August the 1st 1942 by
The Saturday Evening Post accompanied by
the sensationalist title shot down over
Libya the success of the story and the
one-thousand dollar paycheck gave him
the motivation to continue writing in
1943 Dahl published his first novel the
gremlins he was the first to introduce
the name and concept of these
mischievous creatures who caused
mechanical malfunctions to RAF fighter
planes
the novel attracted attention from the
right people Eleanor Roosevelt for
example used to read to her
grandchildren and uncle Walt Disney
invited Dahl to Los Angeles to discuss
an animated movie adaptation the film
was never made but Disney Studios did
publish the illustrated version of the
gremlins by 1944 roles work was in such
demand that he hired a literary agents
in New York and Watkins Dahl had taken
the final step towards becoming a pro
writer
[Music]
so I thought I'd take this cue to
analyze role dolls literary themes
despite the early success of the
gremlins role dolls career took off as a
writer of short stories for adults and
pretty dark ones too three main themes
that recur time and time again are
vengeance a grotesque view of sex and
punishment the most famous example of
the first theme is a lamb to the
slaughter the protagonist is a woman
Gordon mary moloney she is told by her
husband a senior policeman that he
intends to leave her presumably for
another woman
he slighted Mary instantly exact revenge
she kills him with a single bash on the
head from an unlikely weapon a frozen
leg of lamb when her husband's
colleagues come to investigate Mary
roasts the murder weapon and serves it
to the clueless policeman who while
eating speculates on where the murder
weapon might be and then there's another
story and it's got a description of
sexuality that couldn't get more weird
and grotesque the story is Georgie
Porgie here the main character is a
sexually repressed minister who finds
himself attracted miss Roche voracious
but repulsive parishioner George finds
himself sucked into the woman's mouth
where after a futile struggle the
Virginia clergyman is swallowed inside
roads
George can feel the peristalsis dragging
at his ankles as for the theme of
punishment this is often inflicted by
the author upon characters you don't
really deserve their final gruesome fate
pig is about a wealthy New York orphan
Lexington who is raised by his aunt
gloss pan in isolation the auntie
teaches Lexington do despise meat and to
toss em into becoming a vegetarian chef
when gloss pan dies Lexington ventures
into New York ray discovers that he
loves pork he loves it so much in fact
that he goes on a guided tour of a
meatpacking plant without warning
Lexington is strung up by his ankles by
one of the butchers the slaughterer
raised his right hands and deftly slit
open the boy's jugular vein with a knife
a young character meeting a violent fate
inside a factory that's a plot elements
that can be found also in what is today
probably dolls most famous work for
children Charlie in the Chocolate
Factory
this highlights how Dahl explored the
same topics of punishments and revenge
in his
fiction for children as well Charlie was
based on Roald's own memories of testing
candy bars upon which the author grafted
his own take on the theme of retribution
the bulk of the novel deals with a group
of children who are punished one by one
because of their deep-rooted character
flaws which mirror deadly sins like
gluttony greed sloth and envy
speaking of sin some interpretations
have even pointed out how the structure
of Charlie seems to be based on Dante's
Inferno the children in Wonka's factory
like the sinners in Dante's hell are
subjected to punishments which reflect
their transgressions punishments and
revenge can sometimes blur and a great
example of this is in Matilda or another
one of dolls most beloved works the
villain of the piece is the terrifying
headmaster Miss Trunchbull the real
monster who relishes in smashing cake
dishes on her pupils heads or embezzling
her niece Miss Honey out of her
inheritance it will be up to
six-year-old Matilda and her telekinetic
powers to avenge her friends and
castigate the Trunchbull ending her
reign of terror
Matilda's rebellion is also the most
satisfying example of another pervasive
theme in dolls fiction a deep distrust
of established Authority authority
figures are not always portrayed in a
negative light in doll stories parents
teachers grandparents and captains of
industry can be a source of wisdom
warmth and protection but the same
categories are more likely to abuse
their power and perceived respectability
to the expense of the downtrodden
especially children it's often up to
those children whose intelligence and
willpower is regularly underestimated to
ridicule humiliate or otherwise defeat
the powers that be
[Music]
so now it's time to look at the second
part of Roald's life in 1945 Dahle left
New York to be closer to his mother who
was living in AMISOM Buckinghamshire in
southern England in 1946 his collection
of war stories over to you was published
mixed reviews but it eventually sold
enough copies to grant Dahl deal with
him to write another book this would be
a novel about the possibilities of
nuclear war called some time never
published first in the u.s. in 1948 the
novel was a total flop but worth
remembering as the first fiction book
about nuclear war to be published in the
United States after Hiroshima Dahl
wasn't gonna go broke any time soon
anyway in 1950 royalty started pouring
in from the short stories he had sold to
the New York currents other American
publications at the same time he was
starting to grow weary of life in rural
Buckinghamshire the sirens of dolls
glamorous American life were too loud to
resist and the author applied for a US
visa and in 1951 he moved to New York in
the Big Apple he lived as a guest of
Charles Marsh
a newspaper magnate whom he had
befriended in the 1940s Marsh introduced
him to a scene of parties and galas
frequented by celebrities it was at one
of these functions that he met his
future wife 25-year old actress Patricia
Neal the young and promising actress had
made it to the cover of Life magazine
when she was just 21 but by 1951 her
fame was mainly due to offstage drama
Patricia had just ended a long
extramarital affair with Gary Cooper
which started in 1947
despite mrs. Cooper's threatening
telegrams Neal did not call off the
fling and Gary got her pregnant and
subsequently persuaded her to have an
abortion that was the final straw that
convinced the young actress to call it
quits so it was after this trying
experience that rolled in Patricia met
at a dinner party organized by
playwrights Lillian Hellman those tests
at them next to each other at dinner
rolled a notorious ladies man and an
entertaining and sarcastic
conversationalist though he ignored her
the whole evening it wasn't long though
before the two of them were going out on
a regular basis roles professional life
was also on the rise as his second
collection of short stories Someone Like
You attracted good sales and equally
good reviews
Patricia enrolled were young successful
and in love naturally they decided to
marry the wedding took place on July the
2nd 1953 at the
Church in New York the first few years
of married life for the celebrity couple
were almost a picture postcard of
marital bliss well at least on the
surface dolls life would never truly be
free of tragedy the couple moves to
little white fields farmhouse in great
MS and and Buckinghamshire in England
the dolls renamed it gypsy houses this
became Roald's main headquarters for the
next 36 years in the garden of gypsy
house doll built his famous garden shed
which he described as a nest and even a
wound he would withdraw to this shed
twice a day to work on his latest short
story or novel doll was not a workaholic
but he was a very disciplined writer he
dedicated three to four hours a day to
writing every day splitting his morning
and afternoon sessions he never typed
his tools of the trade were six freshly
sharpened pencils and a portable writing
desk resting at an angle on his lap more
importantly his womb was completely cut
off from distractions but it was full of
aides to drive his inspiration for
example mementos from his RAF service
human skull even a piece of his own
femur which was used as a paperweight
there's also an alien looking sphere of
unidentified metal which was in fact the
wrappers for every chocolate bar hit
ever eaten rolled into a solid ball on
April the 20th 1955 the dolls welcomed
their first child
Olivia 21 tal Sofia better known as
Tessa followed almost exactly two years
later and then on the 30th of July 1960
a boy Theo joined their ranks for an
early age the kids would pester all
asking him to come up with new bedtime
stories every night eventually Dahl
decided to commit some of these tales to
writing the first one was about a boy
called James his horrible aunties and a
giant cherry which eventually morphed
into a giant peach of course talking
about James and the Giant Peach the
first of 21 books for children 18 novels
and three collections of poetry Roald
Dahl was no stranger to childhood
illness and mortality we already
mentioned his sister Astri who died of
appendicitis unfortunately he had to
relive similar tragedies with his own
children on December 5th 1960 Co was
struck by a cab in New York aged only
four months he survived but with serious
head injuries which left him permanently
brain damaged more precisely Thea
developed hydrocephalus or the build-up
of fluid
the brain the condition requires for the
fluid to be drained regularly via a
valve fitted in the patient's skull
Theo's valve kept on blocking with
potentially fatal consequences to all
took matters into his own hands with the
help of a neurosurgeon and his friend
Stanley Wade toy maker and inventor the
author developed a new much improved
version of the valve the invention was
peer reviewed in the medical journal The
Lancet and was subsequently implanted in
thousands of children around the world
the doll family was not through with
tragedy yet though in November 1962 the
eldest daughter Olivia fell ill with the
bad bout of measles which progressed
into inkatha lightest on the 17th she
felt floppy and drowsy eventually she
lost consciousness and never woke up
again even on this occasion doll felt
compelled to contribute to medicine in
this case by raising awareness about the
importance of measles immunization his
subsequent essay on Livia's illness and
death is still quoted during Pro and
anti vaccination debates two years later
the doll family had a brief respite from
grief when another daughter aphelion
Magdalena was born on May the 12th 1964
but as I said it was a brief interlude
nine months later
Rahl's wife Patricia suffered three
massive hemorrhagic strokes the right
side of her body was paralyzed even more
damaging for a successful actress the
stroke left her virtually unable to
speak Patricia was hospitalized a month
later doll revealed to the press that
she was five months pregnant and that
the life of the unborn child hung in the
balance Patricia
luckily pulled through as did her baby
Lucy was born on August the 4th 1965
[Music]
patrícia slowly started to recover but
still suffered from speech difficulties
struggling with the names of objects and
people when she couldn't find the words
she invented new ones a drink was a soap
driver a cigarette was an obligor she
would complain to rolled that he made
her Skitch that his cross or that he
gave her the singers ie the depression
dr. Tom Solomon writing for The Guardian
theorized that Pat's made-up vocabulary
may have inspired Roald to create gobble
funks language though can by the BFG the
Big Friendly Giant
but back in 1965 Dahl had other concerns
medical protocols required Pat to
undergo one hour a day of speech therapy
which he believed simply wasn't enough
instead he set up an intensive six hour
a day regimen some professionals warns
this was too much but he ignored them
and Pat was coached back to normal this
miraculous recovery attracted a lot of
attention from other stroke patients and
their families this prompted Dahl to
write a guide on his methods later fully
developed by neighbor and friend Valerie
Eaton Griffith her book inspired a new
approach to the treatment of strokes and
led to the formation of the stroke
association so doll must have been a
fantastic husband and father right well
not so fast
while dolls insistent methods ultimately
curta Patricia was miserable throughout
the whole ordeal and felt in many ways
that Roald was pushing her around the
whole time he was particularly nagging
for her to return to work in 1967 she
later wrote I knew at that moment that
rolled the slave driver rolled the
bastard with his relentless scourge
rolled the rotten as I called him more
than once had thrown me back into the
deep water where I belonged while the
couple appeared very close and had a
large family clearly there were some
cracks in the relationship if one half
refers to the other as a bastard who
gives her the sinkers
there are many accounts from family
members and collaborators which
confirmed that Dahl would have a cruel
and controlling streak at times
bordering on a pathological narcissism
you could also be an avid attention
seeker sometimes resorting to releasing
outrageous statements just to elicit a
reaction in an interview with the new
States many famously claims that there
is a trait
the Jewish character that does provoke
animosity maybe it's a kinds of lack of
generosity towards non-jews I mean there
is always a reason why anti anything
crops up anywhere even a stinker like
Hitler didn't just pick on them for no
reason
second-born Tessa later Ross who had
published author Rhodes with candor
about how rolled was a cold detached
father who was impossible to please for
sure in the late 1960s Dahl started to
detach himself not only from tests sir
but from the whole family
shortly after Patricia's return to the
stage he began an affair with the family
friends Felicity Crossland 22 years as
jr. the affair lasted 11 years 11 long
years during which she contrived to keep
it all a secret from his wife but
apparently not from his daughters Tessa
and Ophelia had found out about it and
he asked them to keep their mouths shut
lest they break up their family
eventually all the DAR girls condones
the affair after they realized that
felicity
was the true love of Roald's life
Patricia was less forgiving eventually
she found out too and in 1979 the couple
formally separated the breakup of the
marriage had a profound effect on all
the children according to biographer
Jeremy Troy Glaus youngest daughter Lucy
had the most extreme reaction developing
a cocaine habit at age 16 two rolls
credits he immediately took action as
soon as he found out taking the blame
for Lucy's addiction and helping her
through rehab and therapy two years
later in 1983 Patten rolled finally
divorced and the author went on to marry
felicity on November the 17th of that
year Patricia accepted the end of his
relationship but did not miss the chance
to quip about it Roald is growing old
but at least I've had his best years now
he's got a nurse for his old age
[Applause]
the last year's of dolls life were
relatively happy and productive and some
of his best-known books were written
during this period
these include The BFG The Witches and
Matilda but these were also the years
where I fell ill with my Leo dysplastic
syndrome a rare cancer of the blood not
even his enthusiastic approach to
medicine could help him on November the
12th 1990 Roald Dahl was admitted to
John Radcliffe Hospital in Oxford in
very poor condition this big perhaps not
so friendly John's of literature died on
November 23rd aged 74 Roald Dahl's
legacy is unmissable and indelible as he
has become the yardstick for all of
children's literature roles the man was
clearly a complicated and difficult
person and may not have lived up to the
moral standards set by Roald the author
so to conclude we'll focus on the latter
by misquoting from matilda with their
message on resisting the cricket
authority of rotten grown-ups dolls
books have given young readers around
the world a hopeful and comforting
message you are not alone so I really
hope you found that video interesting if
you did please do hit that thumbs up
button below and don't forget to
subscribe brand new videos just like
this a couple of times a week also
please go check out another channel I do
called business plays I'm going to link
to that below thank you for watching
[Music]